all right I've gotten a fee request to
review the movie The Smurfs then I
realize if I do a video about the Smurfs
before I do a video about The Avengers
trailer I'm gonna have to jump punch
myself so let's talk about the Avengers
trailer all right if you were stubborn
enough to wade through the end credits
in Captain America
you saw the Avengers trailer if you
didn't I make this video for you
and if you saw it and you want to know
my opinion I also make this video for
you if you're gonna watch this video and
just troll I got nothing all right so
the Avengers trailer starts out you see
Chris Evans just beating a living piss
out of this punching bag he's just going
to town and when I first saw it it was a
bootleg version before I saw it in
theaters and I was like it might still
be fake I don't know then he punches
this thing off the chain and then you
hear samuel l.jackson and he comes into
frame he starts talking with him at that
point I was like yeah it's legit now I
thought to send me al Jackson cameo at
the end of Iron Man was really cool but
7eo al Jackson is Nick Fury I don't know
I want to see if he really becomes the
character in Nick Fury or if he should
just send me all the Jackson with an
eyepatch because that's what it seems
like he seems like he's the guy from
snakes on a plane with an eyepatch so
we'll see how it goes either way he will
be a better Nick Fury than David
Hasselhoff was that's real and it just
shows flashes of different heroes like
Iron Man Scarlett Johansson Jeremy
Renner it's just like one blip of Jeremy
Renner as Hawkeye but even though the
scene it shows a minute is about half a
second long you still feel like you saw
more than you didn't Thor it doesn't
show Mark Ruffalo or the Hulk though is
kind of irritated about that it shows
this one dude walking with a bunch of
guards and you realize it's Loki at that
point I got really excited cuz I was
like dude Loki Loki is just trouble
I like Loki as a villain because when
you see that greasy skinny little
bastard you're like dude bad shits gonna
happen
Thor's got a bit of a different look
though now he's going sleeveless who's
got the Larry the Cable Guy suit from
Asgard and I think Thor's beards a
little darker than the Avengers movie
that it wasn't Thor when they make
changes like that I'm always like did
you have to change it like what couldn't
we have the exact same guy we saw on
Thor apparently after the whole Loki
thing they dress like this now I just
about it now but when the movie
comes out the last thing that's gonna be
on my mind is how Thor looks and one of
the last shots of the trailer you see
Thor Captain America and Scarlett
Johansson that's all I can make out
anyway there might be one other but
seeing them all in the same scene it was
like that's awesome because you've heard
about this Avengers thing happening
since 2008 and now when you see it come
together and you see the heroes
interacting with each other you're like
dude it's actually happening I'm alive
to see it that makes me awesome even
though I had nothing to do with it so it
really makes me nothing and in that last
shot when you see Captain America he's
kind of far away so you can't really
tell the material of his suit to me when
I saw it in the theater his suit looks
like the same material from the Power
Rangers movie I hated it I was like that
sucks it's horrible
to stuck with the 1940s ooh because I
hated the look of it I saw a picture of
him closer and the material is different
than what I thought it was and then I
was good with it so in the end this
trailers like it's not long it's like
less than a minute long but you see all
these heroes from different movies from
the last three years all in one now and
you're like dude it's real it's
happening and that's awesome at the end
when you see Tony Stark say something to
thoria like during the same scene that's
weird and great it shows why the Justice
League movie that DC wants to do that's
just you know it comes out of nowhere no
movies lead up to it it's kind of lame I
wouldn't have gotten this excited for an
Avengers movie if I didn't see like five
movies that were leading up to it it's
like a legacy at this point so did you
see the Avengers trailer what did you
think of it comment below let me know
this is the to talk about right
here and if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]